Sky remembers his credit card in his
head.
His full 20-digit credit card number,
and he won't remember something we
talked about 4 days ago.
>> Oh, she's not
>> He's a special snowflake.
>> Yep, that's us. You might be wondering
how we got here. Wait.
Who are we?
>> Yeah, so I wanted to mention how our
weekly draws, they run from Sunday to
Sunday, right? So, every like Sunday at
8:00 p.m. it restarts. We calculate the
winner for the previous week, and then
we issue the number of tickets to each
user for the next week.
>> Exactly. Um we wanted to test that last
Sunday.
I like call Luke at
>> Mhm.
>> 7:55 p.m.
>> Yo, have fun.
>> Yeah.
>> up your your simulator.
>> Put a timer, make sure you get the
seconds in there, so we know exactly
when it hits 8:00 p.m.
>> It didn't work.
>> Right.
>> Yeah, we we obviously did not have no
time.
>> Yeah.
>> And unfortunately, the the testing
period is going to have to wait till
next weekend.
And we'll be more prepared at that time.
And yeah, that's our debugging update.
>> Yeah, Luke, what do you think of these
animations?
>> I was uh
going through and I found a cool sort of
like pack.
Yeah, so this one for like
>> That's pretty good.
>> earning tickets sort of thing.
Or this one for earning tickets.
>> Okay.
>> This one for like if you're the
>> Oh, wow.
>> I like that spin.
>> Yeah, like this for like when payout is
complete or something.
>> Are these are free?
>> Uh
I think so.
It's free here.
>> Okay.
>> I'll have to download it. Like I know we
have a limit, so it may count towards
our limit. But uh
I think you can just like create a new
account with a different email.
>> We'll definitely make sure that we
respect all um copyright laws and all
that stuff.
>> yeah, yeah. It's It's It's copyright.
It's good. It's It's more of the
platform, which uh we have limits, but
All right. So, basically we uh I set up
Posthog last night. Um Luke's going to
get set up now, and then if you want to
just sort of go through what I did,
check for any errors, make sure it's all
all good, use the MC P server.
Basically, what Posthog is, it's a
analytics tracking tool.
So, uh
we'll be able to see, you know, what
percentage of users who download the app
then actually use it, what percent sign
up, what percent come back every week.
Uh we can run some testing to make sure
that any changes we make are having like
a positive effect on the metrics that
we're tracking.
So, uh yeah, really cool team. We were
like 2 weeks late on their startup
discount, actually. You had to be less
than 2 years old, and we incorporated
like 2 years and 10 days ago. Something
like that. And all they said it's fine.
So, we also got some like free credits,
and I think we can even ask for merch or
something from them. So,
>> Ooh, merch. I love merch.
>> Put on the merch.
>> got the merch right now.
>> Yep, yep. Of course.
The only only hoodies we own.
>> Mhm.
>> All right. so exciting update. We saw a
couple months ago that
someone pretty high up at Wealthsimple
had joined our waitlist. Finally, since
we sent our first email out and whatnot
to the waitlist members,
I decided to reach out to him on
LinkedIn just to connect and
say uh hey, appreciate you supporting us
or at least that we're on your radar. I
don't know if you want to come see Luke,
but he's doing some research on the
concept, found our project, thought it
was pretty cool. So, we're going to have
a meeting with him. So, get to know
about him. I've been watching some of
his podcasts, learning about his stuff,
and uh
where I worked before, I heard great
things about him. Really exciting stuff,
and excited to have that first sort of
conversation with Wealthsimple and uh
see where it leads to.
>> Now, you might be thinking, who is this
guy?
That's me.
The editor.
I came late this day.
I'm also the only one of the three core
members who joined after the founding of
the company.
Here's how that happened.
>> Let's tell them how we met.
And now it's like we're we're breaking
the fourth wall.
>> Oh, we're breaking the fourth wall.
>> know they're there, but we're talking
together.
>> Hello, people.
>> So, Luke and I, we've always been into
poker. Like, our group of friends since
high school we've been playing.
And then we discover people at McGill
run these games.
>> Yeah.
>> So, we show up, and then we meet uh you
know, a bunch of awesome people there.
>> Then we meet you. Rob, Phillip, Shamir.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> All the Gs. Emil.
>> Yeah, you know, obviously I'm like
always sort of pitching the startup.
>> And I'm telling everyone about it. No,
guys, go go go join the waitlist.
>> Yeah.
>> And then you're like, "Hey, yo, like
I've been wanting to be part of a
startup." I remember you telling me
that. Like, "I want to build something
and I want to prove myself and
started talking, and seemed like a good
fit.
>> I think I lost a lot of money in that
game, actually. Like, the game that we
were playing, I think I was down like
150 bucks or something. I was really
pissed. But then Ben, like you told me
about this like cool like random side
business. And I was originally coming in
as a developer as to do code.
>> Yeah.
>> I came home to my girlfriend and then I
told her about uh this like random guy
that I met with a fintech company. He
wanted me to do some dev work for him.
>> Yeah, I remember we like met up at the
library a couple times, did some work
together.
>> Yeah.
>> I sort of like talked a bit about the
vision and where I saw it and
>> For a while I did a little bit of dev
work and then we decided we needed more
growth.
>> Yeah, we need more growth content and
you put me on that. And anyway, that's
what I have fun with.
I like the camera.
>> Luke and I were too uh we're too shy.
>> I mean, hey, we posted our first one.
That was my first video where I'm like
actually in it, you know. Luke, too,
he's in it.
So, uh
now you see, now as the company is more
and more successful, it's going to be a
lot easier.
>> I'm a I'm a bad cameraman. I missed the
action, but the security guard just came
in here and told us to kick us out. Uh
even though we have a 24/7
deal to stay in this space.
So, um
Oh, oh, oh, maybe not. Maybe not. I
don't know.
They tried to kick us out. They told us
to leave. Nobody's stopping us. They're
stopping us. We're leaving in 20. But uh
but yeah, I
the boys are eating.
So, some frozen butter chicken.
Yeah.
And yeah, so we're uh
we're out of here for tonight, but
we continue tomorrow.
>> Okay. So, here I'm going to
purposely not sign in with Face ID.
We're brought back to the sign-in
screen.
Now from here, I'm going to continue
with Face ID.
Oh.
Okay. Well, it was supposed to ask for
my Face ID. So, let's go fix that.
>> So, here's the workstation.
Connected in.
Got You got little devil running.
>> Yeah, I'm on the phone.
>> And I got some stuff running here.
Create personal API Oh, I should not be
showing API keys. Oh, I like that it
zoomed in.
We're approaching our 8:00 p.m. test for
the launch later, in like 2 weeks.
Um the the dev boys are stressing right
now, so I'm filming. Yeah, hopefully we
uh make it. 20 minutes to go.
>> Isn't there a chance that neither of you
win the ticket?
>> No.
>> How come?
>> So, we have two We have two prizes.
We have a weekly guaranteed prize of
$100.
>> Right.
>> Which as long as there is a user,
someone will win it.
That is calculated by the ticket with
the most matches. And if more tickets
have the same number of matches, let's
say me and Luke, we both have a ticket
that has four out of seven matches.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, then one of us will be randomly
chosen as the winner.
>> Okay, so I don't need to get everything
right. I just need to get more right
than anybody else, or get lucky.
>> Yeah, you just get lucky.
>> And that 10K is for what?
>> 10K is if you match all seven, then you
win the grand prize.
Bro, why why why would you talk about
Post Malone again? We already filmed
that last Friday.
>> I forgot, man.
>> This guy remembers his credit card in
his head.
Full 20-digit credit card number, and he
won't remember something we talked about
4 days ago.
>> No, she not.
>> She's a special specimen.
>> No, this she not.
>> First official test run
>> uh in
8 minutes.
>> Yeah, it's hide all the fancy code.
>> So, what's happening right now is it's
almost 8:00 p.m. and at 8:00 p.m. on
Sunday, we're going to get the seventh
number of the draw.
And that's when the snapshot of
everyone's tickets is going to bank bank
account is going to be taken so that the
tickets are going to be frozen for the
next week.
>> Oh, you don't have to watch that.
I'm stressed like
>> Yeah, I'm I'm good to
start testing.
Oh, well, we should delete all users.
>> All right.
>> Yeah, see cuz I'm like I'm logged in so
let's
>> Yes, I'm stressed.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah. Good time. Good time.
Let's go. Let's go. Let's go.
I want the truth.
>> Yeah, cat.
>> have We have spent
>> Let's go.
>> to got to be quick.
Slow the Wi-Fi.
>> I'm setting up right now. So, I'm trying
on the simulator.
>> Oh, I'm going to put real this.
>> Oh, [__]
>> I'm going to get real tickets with
these.
See the speed of the line animation
screen.
>> First, create your account.
And you get the little introduction
here. All righty, now I'm going to do
this.
And then
Yeah, so link the first account.
Link both of them.
>> This one I'm not linking with the bank
account. I'm just going to enter your
code and see if I get my tickets without
linking an account.
>> Cat.
>> Let's try a weird birthday.
Let's go to February 20th.
Cuz what year was was it a week year?
>> I don't know.
>> You went Once you like
>> super smart
>> No, we're we're good like we already
created enough accounts. I'm just I'm
doing extra.
Okay, so we released the winning number
of this week early or I think it's
glitching. Oh, revealing.
What the
Yo, can you fix this? Just for like dev.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Why is it busting around?
>> Yeah, it's it's glitching.
Oh, yeah, it's
>> Did you get the reveal?
>> Yeah, and then it's it's going back and
forth, eh?
>> Okay.
So yeah, it's I don't know why this
screen is moving like this.
Why is it busting around, brother?
Yeah, it's it's having trouble loading
the
the data from the API. So it's like
it's alternating between uh
new screen and then it just goes back
and forth.
>> And it shows like the your tickets
breakdown.
>> Oh, so we got the winner, eh?
>> So so the year no winner this week, so
it probably says that.
Huh.
>> Oh, for that one. Okay, what about for
the every every day winner?
So
>> No, no, so like so it's saying last week
there were no users, so there's no
winner this week.
>> Okay.
>> Now
we'll see in the back end, I guess. So
the front end is not displaying. It
should say that we have like we each got
I should have 100 tickets cuz I used the
waitlist promo code.
>> Right.
>> It says zero. We'll go check the data
see if I actually do have 100.
>> I'm just reading reading the data on it.
>> Yeah, or if they just didn't register at
all. Ooh, you should open your logs see
what it said.
>> I have no logs.
>> I mean I have no logs. You always had
logs.
>> Good.
>> You want to get food?
>> Yeah.
>> Honestly, not bad. We know what needs to
be fixed.
We will investigate deeper, I guess. See
like
um
things are small issues or big issues,
but uh
hey, at least we
>> Yeah, we'll check the database after
>> after supper.
>> Like front end everything basically
worked. Like someone was able to
download the account the app, create an
account,
link their plaid account.
>> Yeah.
>> And view home screen just with bad data.
Right?
>> Yeah.
The number got revealed early.
>> Oh, yeah.
Pretty cool.
>> Did you capture both disappointed fish?
>> Huh?
I'm not disappointed.
No, I'm just waiting I'm waiting for my
one-time password.
>> Progress. Progress.
>> I'm very happy.
>> And now you get to go eat.
>> We will talk about later if uh I guess
about like investing into the company.
>> Ooh.
>> We'll have to balance how much, you
know, like there's no no one's forced to
to put in, but also like then you can't
complain if you get diluted.
>> Tired, man.
Hey, it's only 8:00, man. You got at
least 4 more hours in you now.
>> This guy's like this guy's a early bird
boy.
Yeah, I need I need a break.
Post-game interview?
Good call.
Hopefully we can get the
partnered with us. That's that's secret
for now.
>> Why are you so close, bro?
>> Cut the camera.